Netflix is listening and I think they're
biting at Liberty now
listen folks oh just jump in whatever
you want Shane but you know what we're
so happy yeah
who ordered the cancer patient
come on Sir
make a wish he is God gnome is here just
just put him in Mark's pocket real quick
all right get right between us there
little boy there you go yeah this guy
looks like a [ __ ] morning
was it hard was it hard crossing paths
with Rudy on the way out
there you go there's a hat the
commemorate your Make A Wish For Real
this reporter Gary's Make-a-Wish guys
let's make it count yeah how's the
leukemia going how's the uh
chemo thank you
oh [ __ ] Gary I know your wife you told
her you're stopping drinking I think for
today we mix it up a little bit what do
you have a drink yeah come on guys I'll
take a selfie
why'd you stop drinking yeah paper plane
something you got two kids yeah two kids
I don't know I just slowed down I drink
with him every once in a while on the
road I'll do it I'll do a picture hold
on Gary's gonna slow it down we're not
gonna cheat at the hyper Pace we've
witnessed it
drink for four years then I went to
Vegas for uh and then yeah and then I
broke my variety I was with Andrew
Santino and he was just like you know
it's not a big deal
we're in Vegas
oh yeah he's an absolute pig that kid
I've been like six years
these will [ __ ] you up yeah the planes
are [ __ ] me up yeah they're good yeah
they're putting their [ __ ] lettuce
dog what's your whiskey called
how dare you you know what that means I
was like what are your sandwiches
yeah
all right
wait real quick Gillian keeps is that is
out yeah killing keeves is out now dude
season two
it's on no it's behind a paywall all
right you make some money gilliancieves
dot TV are you gonna put it on YouTube
later like Schultz I don't think so okay
I think maybe maybe like a sketch or two
to try to get someone to watch it but
yeah smart some of the best news max
Gary you're new what do you think
Newsmax yes I don't know much about I
don't know much about it it's a great
black guy
I'm trying now it's hard for you to
break away you live in deep Jersey you
got a wife and kids I have wife one kid
another one on the way you're living
November living his life
go ahead tell them about setting up a
trampoline
there I go again
someone had to be Urban in here
oh my
gosh right yeah
the guy with the no shirt on yeah let's
talk about the price of parking what
time do we have on this never-ending
podcast just doing everyone in the
midwest wants to hear about New York
parking for us long time really a couple
hours two it's quite a party yeah we're
going hard here you're [ __ ] up Shane
we want to do our best Shane was
supposed to come at 2PM I know I wake up
I wake up to a Shane Gillis text with
Mark on it it's supposed to be a
surprise I didn't know it was a surprise
and Shayna and Shane goes I can't make
it a Marco Shane's coming
I don't know that's nice yeah I was
excited yeah I thought you set something
up oh yeah well I did I ruined it you
did I didn't know I didn't know hey well
Matt Peters really set this all up so
yeah you made it again not that stripper
girl what was he up to I wish I was
there for that that would have been nice
it was uncomfortably hot yeah
slightly shaved body
it was like an intervention of strangers
like what yeah it has nothing to do with
my coding problem does it
and now to bring it home Shane's going
to read us the Turner diary
good book and now to bring it home Gary
Robinson tell us about the traffic cycle
oh my God it is miserable out what are
we talking Holland or Lincoln thank you
I took the Lincoln yeah and uh you
seemed like a bridge man to me no I'm a
bridge man every once in a while but
every once in a while I decide to take
the link to get them started they won't
stop
Gary's just all Coke in college oh oh
yeah very unsuspecting yeah there you go
exactly yeah yeah you still yeah
he was ready that perked your ears up
dude with some glow dude we were talking
about that earlier
yeah back in the day was uh yeah Viagra
and some blow but now it's Bluetooth hey
whatever keeps you behind that merch
table I say God bless
for hours watching people walk out I
don't let features sell
Sam yeah I know I love I love future so
no but I can I go apologize to Shane for
a second or no yeah of course because
every time I'm at the cellar and I'm
there late and Shane is just hanging out
you know just wants to hang out I always
try to involve him and he he doesn't
want to be involved so I apologize for
doing that I love when you talk to me
and while I'm on stage
but I I feel like it makes me very
uncomfortable and I'm sorry
yeah wow no it doesn't it doesn't you're
just yeah I'm not good at it and I
genuinely met me back yeah no I really
feel I'm like this guy definitely
doesn't want to do this well no I just I
really want to watch this show I want to
watch Adele you want to watch the show
and I even sit I don't sit in the
doorway I sit in the corner where
hopefully he doesn't see me yes yeah and
I'll be like Shane you like vibrators
don't you like uh yeah she's like good
answer dumbass all right Jesus Christ
what do you want to say a little more
Artful than that but if you have to show
her when you're on stage and somebody
goes I gotta pee but I don't want to
walk through the room because Dave is
going to yell at me and you go [ __ ] it I
gotta pee I'm sorry for using you guys
instead of fighting material walking
into the room on you just you know yeah
Hey so uh and we'll be standing damn
what do you think about this dude I love
when Dave insults
yes if you don't respond Snappy enough
though like you you I've had you go like
this to me where you'll ask me a
question I go uh and you go move
you want to start a deep conversation I
just want a quick laugh and move on to
the next you can't see it but in the
back if you hit a comic and with other
Comics it's like oh [ __ ] it's like oh
he's getting you go go go yeah and then
you say the wrong thing
in the doorway real and Frank if you
either step out into the game or get out
of the room yeah
we're in the corner already uh no we we
did we're intimidated we love well you
gotta step it up down there I mean look
at me I'm an old hack and I need all
that yeah but should we be funny back
because then I feel Cornish oh no now
you're making it feel like it's uh
what's Macaulay so I try to just answer
exactly correct no you should try and be
fine keep it going down there all right
people on Groupon love this stuff the
people come down there I'd love to see
The Interchange it feels like too much
of a risk to try to be funny to you no I
just answer I'm like I'm just killing it
right now but uh
I actually I I do and I do enjoy sitting
down there it's very fun now I know
right now you have your emotional pay
wall up but
I just got give me [ __ ] 10 minutes I
know I'm sorry God damn it
damn it give me 10 minutes I'll be
fighting DeRosa
100 all right that would be fun yeah
right when I walked in with your little
[ __ ]
I said Burke Chrysler's here yeah what
was that what's that mean I mean you're
fat whoa you're chewing right now you're
disgusting dude
it's so much yeah it wasn't dude
you're not even the fifth Beetle you're
the sixth Beetle here no you're
disgusting
that's nasty stuff dude we have such a
nice time you always get drunk
when I see your eyes oh when I see his
eyes
I left Joe's birthday and I remember two
straight years Joe goes you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] and I was like oh it's 2
A.M on a Monday yeah yeah I came to your
[ __ ] birthday on Monday because you
guys should have spots every other day
you can't curse people out from leaving
at 2 A.M
you know it's not a real no no I know
it's a lovingly person we love it dude
Dave's having an episode he fell asleep
that old war injury yeah listen here
Mike uh I need to massage it with punch
lines
yo what was it about on that Monday
black friend
well stay tuned for your next guest oh
[ __ ] this is not really the exclusive
environment that Sam promoted
I'm Jay
you wish oh actually I think I know who
it is
arrested recently okay DJ Young Fly who
do you think it was T.I
no I'm kidding he wasn't he's just black
Hannibal now this show is taking a
horrible turn now that Rudy left I knew
it that guy was that white rage oh
Rooney yeah he was hot
there as we speak or no huh this is
airing now no you got a few weeks right
so I'll be at the um yeah where are you
gonna be dude I don't know what's funny
um you got a lot of work in the fall I
guess you gotta now that you've been
married so you know you gotta is she
gonna go on the road with you no why not
well somebody's gonna take care of the
home what home did that apartment you
bought apartment you're still living
that one in it yeah how do you like that
she like that she doesn't like that yeah
she loves it the nine walk up to a
closet
it's a nice place you guys won't be
living there by next year no yeah we're
looking at Westchester
I'm not allowed in the suburbs you're
not you will not yeah you got to save me
the in the clubs or something yeah I'll
be by the corpse yeah but you got to get
a you know a proper home yeah what
neighborhood are we thinking here I'm
thinking Fort Greene I
yeah I kind of want to move to Brooklyn
too yeah
we'd love to have you happy neighbor yes
you'd be a good Brooklyn girl we could
not do spots together I'm an awesome
Brooklyn guy yeah yeah Gary what do you
think about that damage waitresses we're
both drivers here what do you think
pricing congestion yeah for the uh cars
I don't even know what that is what's
congestion congestion they're gonna
they're gonna charge you extra to come
in during the day no to drive into the
city
I mean I'm paying a fortune right now
this might hurt the podcast Community a
lot yeah it really could you you Gary's
ears perked up when you when you
mentioned getting ripped off oh my God I
mean every every any moment I get ripped
off I'm in a circle I was in a cab once
with this guy and the guy you put a 100
tip in on accident remember that yeah
and the guy was like oh I can't fix it
I'm sorry my friend and you were like
I'm not getting out of this cab till you
fix it yeah we almost fought yeah hey
what's with the accent I can't do Asian
accents but I can
I still got it
came back you're still in the car get
your money's worth for God's sake 100
bucks and the guy was like all right
I'll fix it so he could do it
I'm like you know you have money
podcast I know I would have walked this
is the person who says they can't do
something when they clearly can do it
yep lady closing the door on you at the
uh the airport oh yeah that was a
nightmare yeah they can't do something
but then yeah she shut the door on me on
a connect flight I missed I missed a gig
oh actually you were like running I was
running to get the connect flight she
shut the door as I said please don't and
she goes I'm sorry and she shuts the
[ __ ] door in my face that must have
made her day though yeah you know what I
tried to put myself on her shoes I'm
like that must have felt pretty good
there's nothing more I missed a giggas
like the Titanic sealing the [ __ ]
sorry fellas in the engine room I had to
uh I watched a guy get kicked off my
flight this weekend what'd he do before
takeoff he's on I thought he was on
pills maybe blacked out drunk but he's
just vaping just sitting there vaping
and uh stewardess comes over like sir
you can't do that and he was like
you've kept vaping and I watched the gay
stewardess go up there like
into the phone I knew it was on I knew
something was coming so they act like
we're taking a class of Coach first
class and they wrote I know this guy was
first class on perks just yeah but wow
they left the gate circled around went
to another gate
two black dudes came on and sabotaged
him they're like sir you need to come
with us and he woke up he was like I was
just sleeping what's the big deal and he
gave up right away no fight I was
disappointed I wanted to see his stats I
want to see a fight he got up hit
himself no harder job than the flight
attendant like that's a real tough job
yeah well they have to fight now yeah
they have to fight they're awesome
they're always like I mean they just
signed up for you for United they didn't
think of being uh One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest just [ __ ] yeah it's a
mess I know he got off without a
struggle I was ready to be a hero yeah
he was next to a black lady I was ready
to rescue my black queen yeah
beat the [ __ ] out of a white guy yeah it
would have been nice it would have been
nice but then I was thinking if he
knocked me out
just get sucker punched by a guy on
perks just that would go viral yeah it'd
be rough
you got to know you can't do that he
kept vaping damn the guy comes over and
says please stop shoot him away
yeah with the lithium batteries right
Sam they catch on fire that's what they
say remove them from your on from your
thing how do I get out of this shot and
make him do it uh here's the thing I
will say this when you are on drugs you
don't have any concept that things can
go wrong if you're doing coke you're
just like nothing everybody's doing good
yeah that's what you feel yeah
you must at least miss the travel of
being a comic out there where am I going
where oh delayed all right I'll have a
quiet snack but uh it'll give me a
chance to work on my blog remember that
time I got us out of Tampa on the on the
United flight yeah it was two weeks ago
oh [ __ ]
I already never paid me ah he said he
did yeah I haven't seen a dime well
oh my God
you can use all these laughs for every
podcast if you want
this fight is a hundred thousand miles
and he was just like all right I got it
I got it
you got to get those points a million
miles yeah let's talk points now Gary
what do you think
this is like a Marriott Hilton kind of
guy yeah Envoy all the way yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah good shot
one time I was in Pittsburgh and um we
all went out and then we came back to
the hotel and somebody had robbed the
hotel
and we're like What did they take like
the little soaps and stuff like that
like did they take all that little stuff
yeah but they like basically came in and
it's like can I help you and they robbed
the hotel I was like how cool is that
you know like wow just felt like the guy
behind the counter like you know because
we all know late night at the hotel they
have that Indian dude sleeping in the
back security thing we have to like buzz
that was before that it's the Indian
Family behind the desk guy comes out at
three in the morning in his pajamas hey
what's up he's cooking something in the
back you can smell the ramen or whatever
[Laughter]
I like a nice Residence Inn I like a
place do you like it I like we can do
your laundry well yeah
as far as the mainstream change go I
look at the Marriott I figured more as a
boutique hotel man yeah a little Airbnb
gigantic uh Tick-Tock toe board you
sleep instead of a Pac-Man machine
there's a hammock in there no I really I
as far as the chains go Marietta I find
always kind of delivers a satisfaction
oh hell yeah dude middle of the road is
the best because the four C's is too
much because the Wi-Fi is 18 the
breakfast is 90. yeah I don't want to
hate can I say this yeah
the dummy I can't stand them I'm with
you it's really you talking about women
the W's too much neon yeah it's like
there's like oh look there's a telescope
next to your bed and that's your sketch
or whatever they're stupid the most
overrated Hotel chain I agree I agree
Keith Robinson it's his favorite Hotel
chain and I tell him he's I I've said to
Keith you are the most black white trash
human being I've ever met my life you
have to say it after right after a
second stroke I didn't think hey
Different Strokes
are the same folks but he loves the W
and I feel like slapping you Joe because
I know he can't
[Laughter]
you're saying he's you're saying he's
half he's white trash and black
which side do you think is white trash
probably the side that's still working
yeah
come on Dave nice I did that for you
all right I really need a podcast to
show up to make that one land yeah let's
just black gas we need them quick where
is he no more black jokes he's a talk
you only hear at the Indy 500. oh yeah
do some milk dump some milk is he late
all right wait who's coming guys thanks
for having me I don't know it could be
anyone anyway I stayed at a Grossman
Hotel your buddy oh nice hotel I didn't
know he had hotels
yeah the one that he puts uh and it was
just the worst worst [ __ ] places
pubic hairs in my bed in St Louis it
sure wasn't a condo wasn't it yeah
pubes in the in the bad pubes on them
towels it's a lot of pubes yeah he
wasn't coming from him I know yeah I
wish yeah
sure they were pukes
probably just a black person what curly
no like they're you know small little
and then yeah I know people can you
sleep through the night in the hotel
because I have trouble and even when I
get home now I feel like it carries
it becomes interrupted sleep you know I
have to run out and smoke anyhow but
it's still like uh the hotel like I
don't know it doesn't really work for me
anymore you know about sleeping in a
hotel I bet you guys I take drugs you do
what do you think a little something to
put you down it's called Seroquel so it
helps you sleep through the night nice
you take that [ __ ] no good I mean that's
like hardcore stuff is it yeah is it
prescribed yeah weren't you taking
[ __ ] you got it from mans right yeah
yeah because when you buy when you buy
even like uh like prescript like legit
let's call them legit drugs it's legit
when you buy them from guys that aren't
official they're putting the what what
the [ __ ] is the stuff they're putting on
all the federal no oh
oh wow at the border where they've said
like these are
identical to like Adderall or whatever
it is and they're just fentanyl pills
like you you have to be careful with
that okay all right well the guy I'm
getting them from is pretty up and up no
that's what you think everybody is it Dr
Oz
but you got to be careful with that all
right all right you got to be careful
with that fentanyl you better be very
careful right you better be careful if
you're doing fentanyl yeah oh boy
yeah okay you're down to just smokes and
caffeine and drill wrap don't that's my
guilty pleasure
you give a shout out on the corner where
you're going to be and tell me to take
care of business I'll come down there
guys thanks for having me on the podcast
I love that you guys uh you know
honestly this is so much fun and um
Mark really congratulations to you thank
you Dave I appreciate it it's great to
see everybody it's good tonight
Fire and Ice my friend
yeah please don't talk about me when I
leave how long will this go on for
that's what I want to know um
skank Fest in Las Vegas he's also going
to be at Clark Ridley's on October 20th
and uh he's going to be a Louisville
Comedy Club yes Louisville Helium Comedy
Club in St Louis and uh Pittsburgh
improv yo look a little good nights in
Raleigh check out Dave's website for
more dates he's a killer one of the best
the best I can't wait for the good the
Roses relapsing on pretzels
thanks man thank you Sam you're the best
Dave so who else is coming in I want to
know oh it's a surprise
one more surprise guest what do we get I
smell a ventriloquist oh please is it
piff the Magic Dragon the rose is good
over here Piper's busy we tried I want
you here those Americans guys yeah
right how was that show was that a
nightmare that was the worst experience
why was that so bad you did it yeah they
keep you waiting yeah they know what
they're doing America's Got Talent you
feel like you know a piece of [ __ ] but
when you're doing the show
ruined your life oh yeah I did last cop
it was the same format yeah you just I
mean the constant waiting around they
have you know they'll be [ __ ] up you
have to bounce stuff
I can't [ __ ] drink yeah usually I'll
catch him I gotta go to dinner with my
[ __ ] girlfriend and her family what
are you guys I'm gonna get [ __ ] up I
don't know you can blame it on me your
friendly neighborhood yeah she's a great
egg you don't know what you're doing it
yeah we'll see yeah thank you for saying
that's awesome yeah she's very sweet
where are you guys uh going she sent me
a history book yeah it was right yeah
what what where are you guys going
together uh I don't know I don't know
but in the city somewhere in Long Island
Long Island oh yeah her sister and
brother-in-law live in Long Island we're
gonna meet between queens and where they
live are you not with the family yeah
they're great they're all her she's from
Long Island they're all like nice
Midwest women that are like yeah hey
yeah oh you're having a couple drinks
yeah
no problem with alcoholism yes they're
all of them how long you been dating her
uh like almost two years nice yeah she's
a fun lady yeah she's fun that's great
so you know what she does when it's very
nice is she gets so drunk she falls
asleep oh wow every time I play Drunk my
wife punch me in the face yeah she's an
alcoholic she's a plate thrower oh my
god oh yeah it was a while every once in
a while I catch a bad drunk with my
girlfriend she's like yeah man like out
of nowhere it'll be like she seemed like
a cheery drunk she is yeah
she's very happy and then she falls
asleep and it's like all right let's go
home yeah yeah yeah let's get a good big
gay photo
the podcast still going taking a group
photo
thanks for letting me smoke in here yeah
yeah
[Music]
thanks Dave thank you we love you Dave
all right I'll see you guys later yeah
we'll see you tonight I can't believe we
got Dave here man we tried to load all
the stuff
you didn't tell me it was uh
I mentioned it earlier
no I was kind of like no I think I
mentioned it early on in the text but it
might have gotten lost like I was like
who will make Norman excited I was like
Gillis Patel and my head I'm like who's
a guest that will make more Peter I just
showed up he didn't show it up
he just comes here yeah he gets on the
elevators
I think people that would like that
Mark's super pumped to see roses
he doesn't know I'm saying this I love
Durant so much we all do yeah I'll talk
to you later he's such a little [ __ ]
though
those Egyptians they did the right thing
yeah the best they knew he was adopted
by an Italian family he does have
Pharaoh body though oh yeah very Royal
Egyptian box where are you going look at
him he's getting more [ __ ] chicken
possibly the most underrated actor I
swear
oh I'm glad that's over sandwiches rap
comedy acting Beast dude great hang
arguably the best hang oh yeah I can't
tell if you're being nice no we [ __ ]
love you dude
I never doubt you're sincere
what are you talking about all right
every time we're together it's I need to
note it he takes the first shot every
time true I come in I try to be nice I
don't want to take shots you're saying
that as if that's like a character thing
Joe has a drinking problem
I don't go around being mean how dare
you both sandwich problem
you have a lot of problems actually you
got pretty good sandwiches dude yeah the
body's a problem
those chicken nuggets are weird they're
like Ranch flavored
wait we're the spicy chips because beer
do you want us to try these spicy chips
where
the good catch the one ship should we
try these one ship challenge [ __ ] that
dude I already did that on taste buds
I'm not doing that really extremely
spicy tortilla chip inside now it's a
bachelor party Reaper pepper guys eating
chips
damn think out of Tail's gone we can be
fine I know we can be ourselves holy
hell I love Dave but I I don't want to
upset him I come he apologized to me
that was crazy that's crazy yeah right
there he was like sorry at the cellar
first of all it's actually a field
around I'm always I'm always right
before him right I'm always on The Late
Show yep and then uh
yeah I was I thought I did well the last
time
I need to have a chip just a [ __ ] I'm
telling you it's it's already one on
taste buds it's brutal like not tell you
I'm telling you yeah but always I like
how you guys are still alive
it's gonna be fine I promise yeah geez
it comes in One Singular pack dude I'm
telling you guys dude it's brutal do it
you said you're fine literally like that
she was going like yeah by the way your
mouth's numb right now
in case I can't handle this oh yeah
I'm telling you right now smell that's a
weird scent yeah that stuff jeez you'll
be fine yeah
oh man it already hurts just the tap on
the tongue you are though one chip in
the whole thing no I don't know that's
how you know it's serious
yeah girlfriend shut up just happy on my
tongue it hurts no I have to this is
gonna be bad it's kind of a Wasabi where
the oh my God the [ __ ] packet is
spicy oh my God I got it you're doing it
I already did it how much you just
killing me how much is it a nibble I'm
trying to nibble Free Fall have you
tried this beard you what
feared you yeah the beard you try this
the spicy chip oh yeah I did wait is he
actually Jewish no no no he's tall as
[ __ ] yeah you know he looks like he's
like maybe the tallest Jew of all time
you're pretty tall Jew yeah he looks
German six three go away
can we get around a shot Spirit you oh
we don't need shots oh shut up all right
don't disrespect DeRosa
don't you dare disrespect yeah I took a
nibble and it's heavy duty my tongue is
hurting
oh you're [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] you hate spices I can't believe you
did that
spicy food and I'm hurt oh ew your mouth
yeah it's blue dude it's like eating ass
oh my oh my God
jeez someone joined me please oh
that's done for thank God Dave's going
we can have a good time
God I was nervous oh you're eating chips
on a podcast
I'm really sorry yeah exactly I told you
what why don't you listen because I
don't listen it's a glass of oat milk
oh that's nice dude that's that
stripper's [ __ ]
Rudy why'd you do that
too oh my God hungover with me oat milk
tomorrow's gonna be hell hell that chip
in your belly tomorrow
here we go God [ __ ] damn it oh my God
yeah it's no joke not just like a nib
give feeder some coke to sell yeah I
can't I can't I'm driving how do people
have that whole [ __ ] trip Jesus
Christ I'll crash dude already ate the
whole thing dude I'm telling you he was
like the whole gag was you have to eat
it and then like debate with us and he
ate it and he was like as he was
debating he was like shaking
tears and sweat were coming out it was
yeah look I don't think I've ever said
can we say public him on taste buds is
the my favorite literally my favorite
Clips possible
no doubt yeah
and you're very good at the the face is
just like damn
like it's a perfect
you're the least likable dude
but I took less than years
old enough to be your father yeah
how about the KFC and Penn Station
whatever it goes down there yeah we did
that you remember the TGI Fridays TGI
Fridays
and the McDonald's
me Norman I think James Smith possibly
wow dude I miss James Smith so much I
remember one night I was leaving Gotham
and it was raining hard out and I
watched James all these women were
trying to get a cab and I watched James
just cut right in front of them take the
cab they all screamed you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I just watched him laugh
getting in the cab yeah he didn't even
know I was there my favorite I witnessed
that just as like oh this is James Smith
he's the funniest favorite things ever
to me uh we were hanging out drinking it
was me him and Rachel fine tonight
he goes
what the [ __ ] do you do during the day
the Russia right and I go
I don't know one comic I do shows at
night whatever
and he goes here
shame your names are the days aren't
filled and I go what do you do during
the day and he goes
a lot of administrative work man
what I don't get it foreign
[Laughter]
that's the point of the story
oh okay okay now he's James Smith is a
[ __ ] great another shot
for the viewers at home it's four it's
11 A.M what is this here James Smith I
rode in a cab with him once and he's
going oh oh the Bo in this cabbie what's
the deal mate and the guy's like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you and he's like oh why'd you
get a shower mate [ __ ] you and I was
like shut up man what are you doing I
didn't know you could do that yeah
no problem yeah just the bo is good no
no wait where's James Smith from
Australia yeah that's what I meant the
foreigners white foreigners are like
[ __ ] Indians up here disgusted it's
like yo bro exactly exactly dude they
have no idea how good whites are in them
you would love James Smith that dude's a
[ __ ] sounds like
Australians
the [ __ ] he would say would we went into
a deli once when I lived in Hell's
Kitchen we went into the bodega I
haven't pissed once by the way
shut up and the guy's ringing us up and
he goes when's the next attack mate
and I was so embarrassed I think I
started laughing he goes ah [ __ ] you man
[ __ ] you and he goes no let us know man
I was like these guys can just like you
said they can say whatever yeah
Australians should be they should be the
best at stand up they should be I think
they're gonna be well you got Jeffries
give him another 10 years Australia's
gonna be the best
politically correct over there they are
they're Canada now yeah they're like
yeah I was just over there Australia's
Canada well when they come over here is
like
glorious yes it just came out of your
mouth
so yeah when I went there they were like
because I think they're so they're so
racist that they go hard the other way
like they overcompensate by getting mad
at them you can't talk about Aborigines
yes
yeah of course you're like Hey listen
this doesn't matter yeah we're allowed
to make fun of aboriginals yes and
they're all like
no like no it was it was just be ruined
it for them no that's fine look it was
so fun and funny and now she's like no
they're they're still fun and funny
really yeah yeah in fact the probably
their social pressure to make them more
PC is going to make them funnier you
think so yeah you're gonna get a bunch
of Australian dudes being like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] yeah that's funny because they're
animals deep down we've met them they
come to comedy shows they're [ __ ]
wild yeah they're wild they're drunk
yeah
it's like a real rag tag kind of uh
thing but like what but like you're
saying they're getting like soft yeah
they got hit with like it was pretty
strict during coven they got like Canada
pretty strict it was real yeah they got
strict and they're very so when we went
through BLM they got every other country
had to pretend they were also not racist
so they all had to be like yeah here's
our thing that we need to atone for so
Australia went hard with Aborigines
right aboriginals I hope I'm saying it
correctly yeah I don't don't offend the
natives of Australia
you know it's never a good word when
you're not trying to offend I think the
term is savages
but natives is totally fine the
the yeah they're native they're usually
like original people what do we offer
them all the [ __ ] different uh
original people
coming from other people literally off
on the uh
[Laughter]
wait you didn't even do the last one I'm
sipping me
I got a night ahead of me too
we're going to dinner at Norman and me
and V we are yeah we're going to dinner
yeah I'm driving you guys going to
dinner you guys didn't invite us
[Music]
steady in oh are you kidding you want to
come I wanted to go there last night
you got to get a bump in you you're
you're on yeah
he needs one let's finish that one and
get another one you coward
oh look he's talking where's yours right
here bro oh [ __ ] dude you dude's got a
full basement here's the episode
Dave left of the Dave knows when to
leave God I had six drinks I'm flying
big drinks
got you [ __ ] up
uh oh 6 30. oh you'll give spots tonight
I do but I might have to cancel I do too
I'll tell you right now you're gonna
have to cancel those dude really wait 6
30 that's two hours from now oh yeah bro
we're just getting warmed up here anyway
cheers hey mazelton you better take that
as a shot I just took the last holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] I just touched my dick with
the chip
[Music]
touch my dick and I'm starting to feel
the burn welcome to the party
why'd you do that that wasn't very
strong I wasn't thinking don't wipe your
eyes yeah how's your that's the worst my
tongue hurts my dick hurts more than my
tongue
well your dick's not used to this kind
of spice a lot of guys don't know eyes
worse than dick
[ __ ] oh hey
wait is there anyone else coming yeah
there's one more guy and he's gonna be
ambushed
you'll say do the shot I can't be sober
around this this is terrible it's not
it's not God for you let's just say it's
a God I can't tell you who's coming is
it is it Greer Barnes he likes a
cocktail Rod it's your ride this is
gonna go sideways right now dude I wish
we can't handle shirat this is like clue
we should get sure
yeah yes dude you're gonna die yo you're
gonna be dead dude we're going to Old
Homestead dude
oh yeah you're gonna be fully coming
with me he couldn't make it to this he's
coming to the steakhouse sweet man you
got I I am actually heard a little bit
that you guys were like I thought you
didn't invite me to the you are invited
right now yeah now that I've addressed
how was your reservation cup and hoped
everyone would come no that's fine what
do you know about Old Homestead my mouth
is on fire it's the most famous it's my
favorite all of the oldest ew dude
cancel with you I cancel with you family
I truly come get drunk with us
no I can't because it's not just me and
her it's her family and she was like
what day is it gonna work well that
makes sense and I was like all right
here's one day and she was like all
right block it off
since from 1868. oh look at Nathan died
in Gangs of New York whoa
whoa no it's not dude my dick's on fire
my dick is hurting so badly right now
that sucks put your dick in oat milk
should I do it yeah get me the cop
uniform and I'll do it
you would be able to dip your dick into
a cup who couldn't it's a cup you should
fill it up high my friend was a real
piece of [ __ ] in college and he used to
fill people's beers up with his dick in
the glass and he'd look at me and he
given the beer oh yeah that's pretty
funny sack of [ __ ] he was a bad guy what
a real terrible guy I think it's funny
yeah you're a guy who would always you'd
[ __ ] on the top of the toilet yeah
that ruins the toilet
I remember watching my friend there was
a we were at a house party it was one of
those greats on the floor for the Heat
and he [ __ ] in that yeah you're the best
yeah real [ __ ] up for your ladies
dinner I don't give a [ __ ] at least I'll
be able to talk are you on good terms
with the family already yes that's good
normally I I'm pretty quiet if I'm sober
or something like this I'm just
same Dead Silence a little especially
because the whole time they'd be like oh
you're the sketch show came out I know
it's you are so good at Trump dude
that's I will say yeah
the Trump one it hits me different just
because
you you it's to take Trump and make it
not hacky is it takes a lot of skill
thanks dude that's why it takes a lot of
love dude well no it does you kind of
have to yeah you gotta you gotta not go
dude I was watching Colbert last night
they had [ __ ] Nancy Pelosi really
dude it was she was on there yeah she
was the guest and they were like how
about they showed a picture of Biden
with Kamala Harris and her behind him at
the State of the Union and they were
like isn't it cool that you broke the
glass ceiling and now there's two women
behind the president and it was
obviously they wrote this out and she
was like what if it was just three women
up there not a female president and two
females oh crap dude there was literally
a dude in the crowd that was like
you can listen to the crowd react and
there's a dude going
for real the gayest dude of all time and
so we can hear the gayest dude of all
time yeah what happened to fun it's like
dude that would be incredible
you know the uh the lineup is uh
ratings-wise it's gut felt then Colbert
Gutfeld dominates dominates I gotta be
honest with you I call her pick Rosie
Nancy Pig Lucy she's hot she's got great
cams you don't want to see those cans
yeah well they can now you know but
people are saying that they're not old
that she got implants oh no I want to
see this challenge clearly they're
saying they were subsidized I think you
think those are real people she's like
80. yeah she's got work done you think
my 80 year old tits look that good wow
this is just a Brazier or a holding
above but even still no she has massive
cannons we all agree on that huge cans
Joe you're a Statesman of jacking off yo
you've got massive cans
[Laughter]
giant tits
but Joe's never done Colbert
all right yeah
uh
huge cans yeah it was it was it was the
craziest thing I've ever seen Colbert
brought her on and then they talked
about how important it was to vote
during these elections so that the
Democrats
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you guys have made some noise before
hell yeah it's money I need it I need
I'll be right back how many spots did
you do yesterday huh yeah I did four or
five I think it's like weekend spots
here right
David tell just left of course he did
yeah he had to go do a spot that uh you
know the support Authority
[ __ ] Joe
man Nigeria didn't make it
no no uh is it going to be God really I
knew I just saw him yesterday oh yeah no
JJ a coach of this year huh no one coach
out at old school [ __ ] huh
yeah what's up what's up dude do you
need a drink are you good yeah Coke all
right all right give him alcohol Joe's
got Coke I'm not good at alcohol wait no
no you never drink not really yeah even
in college you'd be a good drunk
or the worst
a lot of Pacino
they're not too strong I do oh you know
what I do there's a thing called the
Shandy you ever heard of that you take
like
um no no no you get like Sprite and mix
it with um Guinness
that's a Jamaican thing it's so good yes
really yeah dude Jamaicans get through
because yeah Nigerians love my father
always had a lot of Guinness we had a
lot of Guinness Guinness which is an
Irish yeah yeah yeah but the lager it's
thick so I always had Guinness in the
house and we'd mix it with the salad
it's so good you know what that's a nice
Red Bull and Guinness oh really Red Bull
and Guinness Red Bull and Guinness yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's what you make it
that's the Jamaican drink yeah you think
it'd be terrible it's not bad I mean you
will you're gonna throw up really I
drink some of it and I I can't drink
like you guys you know Jamaicans
invented chocolate milk I can't it's
just fun fact is that true yeah gross
after a while fun fact wait what's up
what's the jamaican's event in chocolate
milk
hey I like that black history even
February go ahead Mark yeah I got one
you know what's nice about the the steel
drums you know why that's Caribbean
because it was all the steel drums that
they were using to ship out all the
exports they were using but the the
black dudes down there were like of
course we can make some drums hell yeah
[ __ ] real [ __ ] I love it
take a sip of the oat milk oh just jizz
what no one no yeah what's going on here
[ __ ] don't drink it don't drink it
wait what are you doing why are you
doing that [ __ ] why why you guys doing
drinks I don't do that why you guys
doing this he dipped his penis
thank God why would you do that he's
gonna be funny for the bachelor party
yeah [ __ ] you know what just reminds me
of when I went I did uh when when Eddie
if and Jim Jefferies had a podcast in
Venice I did years ago and it was me
sigura and some other and they were all
jerking off and in Glad bags what no no
zip locks let's see if we can and I
didn't do it I was just like what the
[ __ ] are you all doing because that's
good and that's why it reminds me of you
did stick your dick in there
I feel like I have a lot of growing to
do as a person
oh no that's cool don't worry about it
that's cool
that's cool as hell
God damn it dude our first black guest
just showed up the whitest [ __ ] possible
[ __ ] you're predictable
yeah
Godfrey showed up yeah yes I am the
control of this
Antics we had a sleepover when I was a
kid and we had our one black friend stay
over and we put his pinky in water
because he wanted him to piss himself
and he flipped he woke up and he was
like what the [ __ ] girl standing above
him and he just started switching it yes
we only got hit yo Courtney Reynolds
he's a comedian he's a Jamaican dude
he's from Philly I do this nice little
fun trick I do you see where the horse
hit me
it's always I did that to him he forgot
my balls I did that to him let's just
grab my balls that's a fun joke
[Laughter]
[Music]
the black dudes in the locker room
they're like
it makes it funnier yeah you go you show
everybody
because the white dudes would be naked
the longest they're like what the [ __ ]
black guys came up with no homo right oh
really yeah
I think Hitler I think Hitler they even
say no I think Hitler came up with Noah
pretty severely
dude I literally tweeted that I was
watching the Ken something about
watching the Kensington
and
age a management company who's trying to
sign me literally wrote me a text today
saying uh we also watched we want to
sign you we also watched the king Burns
Holocaust Dock and we were equally
Disturbed I was like this is your
[ __ ] method
we found the Holocaust to be horrible
how would you like to team up yeah no
[ __ ] Jared Logan had a really funny no
homo joke he's a funny guy yeah
homo where they compliment each other
yeah when they compliment yeah
I compliment he goes I compliment guys
and I say Jesus
and then I dropped to my knees and put
my mouth up to their crotch and go
Jared Logan is [ __ ] remember remember
Jared Logan's bit about you go to a
friend's home and you're like oh you own
Great Gatsby uh Where the Red Fern Grows
a separate piece you seem to be a huge
fan of required reading
it's a great Jared Logan bit he's funny
dude he's funny he's still alive right
okay
yeah he just moved to L.A that's how we
talk about people who went to California
yeah
we're not sure yet you leave that you
leave the East Coast you [ __ ] died
bye it's never too early to play holiday
music and it's never too early to start
thinking about gifts whether it's just
for a friend or the friends of your
pants
your penis in your balls you can make
this season to be jolly with manscaped
their Platinum package has it all the
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and weed
whacker nose and hair ear hair trimmer
now the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and
the weed whacker nose and ear hair
trimmer they feature proprietary
Advanced Skin safe technology to protect
your delicate parts and your holes both
are waterproof so you can shave in the
shower sounds classy to me don't forget
to apply to the for their aluminum-free
Ultra Premium deodorant for that cologne
quality scent on the go manscaped is
even thrown in two free gifts the
manscape boxers and the shed travel bag
the Platinum package 4.0 covers all your
bases from head to toe tell them how to
do it Mark here's what you gotta do get
20 off and free shipping with code drunk
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
drunk manscape get your jingle balls
ready for the holidays wait a minute so
the Jerusalem Post picked up your
free Palestine Heckle hi to Heckle in
Nebraska over the weekend a woman yelled
out and Gary was there by the way
Palestine you [ __ ] dirty Jews
you told me on the phone yeah we
we popped their eyes yeah I said I want
to do your [ __ ] bus yeah yeah he told
me about this so what happened was this
woman uh this woman out of dude Epstein
joke and she I was at free Palestine I
was like weird timing all right whatever
actually she's exactly right he was
Mossad go ahead
so we started rolling with it and she
just keeps going and it turns into a
whole thing and I'm trying to be as calm
as possible and nice as possible but I
[ __ ] post the thing because I think
it's a hilarious encounter and the
Jerusalem Post the headline is uh a
woman at Sam at a comedian show yells at
free Palestine the Jewish comedian
offers her a drink
ah really that's the headline because I
said what are you drinking I'll get you
a drink that was my commute
that sucks to be identified by a race
[Applause]
in the article in the article it says
openly Jewish comedian I was like openly
Jewish I didn't know I had a choice
I didn't know I could have come out to
my parents
mom sit down
my foreskin is gone
the Jerusalem Post the Jerusalem Post
folks my remote control has more of
range
was that Andy Kindler or dice
Andy uh Dutch handy Dice
look how drunk the Roses
I exercise
[Laughter]
uh black people
it's a fetish that's a fun thing we do
as whites
you know you're right man I'm on it man
I love this man
you you woke man yeah
you'd be surprised
I'm not surprised [ __ ] I should
Sparta kick you down dude for that joke
just being a disgusting Egyptian dude
he's a North Africa right on West okay
that's what Patrice used to say to me uh
oh yeah you call me if you talk to you a
lot what would he do he would call me
every Thanksgiving and he would go here
we go yeah here you go you go Joe man
it always sounded like it was like
the advice
I'm just trying to I'm having
Thanksgiving man so I just want to
invite you you know yeah and I go trees
I can't I gotta go see my mom and dad
and you go Joe
you a dirty
African [ __ ] like the rest of us
stop uphold me a [ __ ] white
Traditions
he would call me at for the summer uh
barbecue and he'd go hey African listen
yeah he's like I know you don't got to
get a lot of food but uh there's an
African you can wipe the Flies off your
face and come over to the pool oh my god
oh that's how Patrice talked to him he
just shouted but he wanted you to come
but he had to [ __ ] on you first yes yes
before that's what Patrice remember one
of the last conversations I had with him
when he was he trashed me on uh Opie and
Anthony we won't open anything together
and they were plugging my dates and he
goes he goes uh after they plug my hands
he goes Joe who you opening for on those
dates right and I was like ah
and then he call me later today
I go hey hello and he goes Joe man
I just listen man the only difference
between me now and me then
I wouldn't have called a [ __ ]
back then to say I'm sorry but I'm sorry
I didn't mean it and you're like dude
you're calling me to apologize right now
and you sound like it was my idea
yeah I didn't think you were I didn't
think he was gonna pull out of that
story yeah yeah
I didn't ask you to call me remember
remember the the uh the [ __ ] what was
it Charlie Sheen Rose was it Charlie
yeah he called me after that and Patrice
he called me he said he said hey
she said [ __ ] last night I was like yeah
I watched it I said you dude you were
dope as [ __ ] you made it so like
different it was different he goes yeah
they just wanted to see the fat [ __ ]
[ __ ] bomb
all right [ __ ]
he said they got me like he was mad that
he was last yeah
he was so angry but it's also tough to
go first and they always put Geraldo
first that's a tough spot too yeah I'd
rather go first though yeah knock it get
it out the way well Patrice said that
was the 20 years of experience he pulled
out of his ass just to make that work
yeah it felt like they didn't feel like
jokes that felt like riffing yeah that
was his genius yeah it was really good
with William Shatner where we go Captain
Kirk you a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you I
was like
like you said I was like I think he just
is riffing this yeah it was a Jeselnik
that was the last white name I want to
remember Galifianakis was hard enough
that was all you tell he was riding that
while sitting yeah yeah yeah he goes yes
he goes just he goes Jess uh Open Mic or
something right no no
no no he goes Jessamine and he goes I
refuse to know his [ __ ] name yeah
and he goes Galifianakis was the last
goofy white guy in this funky town yeah
yeah that's a great sentence yeah goofy
white names amazing that was a good one
yeah very man I was very close to him I
would sit in his truck and he'd just be
talking [ __ ] you know and and I remember
you talk about gigs like he said I don't
leave the house if it's over if it's
less than five thousand I ain't leaving
the [ __ ] house damn like I'm like oh
well I got a gig and yeah I'm going to
get him for 4500. I gotta go to West
Nyack
then he would say yeah he goes man
listen man I [ __ ] up a lot of [ __ ] on
purpose and because I was talking about
Twitter at the time I said yeah man I'm
trying to get followers he goes
man
yeah he's like I would rather have 10
000 [ __ ] that [ __ ] with me than
a hundred thousand that ain't [ __ ] right
he said yeah he would talk he would he
would give me a lot of good advice I
wish I was black I would say stuff like
that I know [ __ ] I'm gonna be white and
I'm like well you you well you need to
work on your social media
we always say yeah social media is very
important quality and quantity Tick Tock
YouTube shorts and reels can you bleep
can you bleep this name if I tell this
story
but can you bleep it
no it was it was uh we we had uh we had
we would both be managed at the same
time with the same guy and and so was
this other person and I was standing on
the street waiting to go in and meet
with my manager and Patrice was coming
out for a meeting and he was sitting in
his car and
was walking down the street it was
going up to have a meeting with them too
and
keep walking up
just what
it pulled his window up I said
Patrice put the window back and he goes
I'm sorry Joe I just couldn't get any of
that on
[Laughter]
and I know that's the thing
I love him wow it was awesome it was
amazing in that game show did you do
that which one the game show you were
hosting oh it never never took who are
you hosting I had a I got a called in to
host this game show because somebody
dropped out and who dropped out do you
know I don't know but it's bigger than
me
more important than me and so they
called me and I did my thing but I don't
think my thing is what they want you
know yeah especially the guns yeah
that's what I did that's what I did
oh
yeah
you are a psycho dude
yeah he's crazy you are crazy I'm doing
comedy I thought that's what you're a
good Sega but he's a mellow psycho sure
you are you could have gone the other
way hello that's true you could have
dummered out could have murdered people
yeah instead you just do okay on stage
yeah yeah
you thought about it obviously I've got
a family now
a couple of guns
that sounds like a great idea actually
get some going get a hotel room
really good yeah you can have like you
can get a license to have a gun in New
York
yeah it's about damn you know how I knew
it was going to [ __ ] because finally
people on the subway will be packing
heat that's uh already wants to get cuts
that makes me so what he's hosting that
makes me answers with those tight suits
he can't even happen you might have a
detective
yeah let me get them some champagne
by the way that does they should if I
was a Democrat I'd be running I'd be
running a commercial of already buying a
gun
and just being like are you sure you
want second amendment rights it's just a
dude dressed like Conor McGregor buying
a [ __ ] handgun lady's purse Keith
Robinson
there you go [ __ ] dumb Hardy last
night
you might be drunk enough
holy [ __ ] I was making fun of him
she's like Hey Hardy I'm sick of you
yeah you bug me I can't stand your suits
can't stand nothing do Steve Harvey
Steve Harvey oh hell no I'm gonna tell
you right now
this is a goddamn good podcast
dude Steve Harvey as Mark hosting a game
show
I'm gonna tell you something Jews hey
who's the winner black family white
family
controversy
David Taylor
[Laughter]
the black family's leading the white
family racist
oh yeah oh yeah I did State them for
State though what on Opie and Jim I did
it first because Jim called me and said
dude you gotta come State and Statham's
promoting a movie you gotta come and so
I come over there I meet Jason Statham
wow and I'm like standing in we're
talking I go when the [ __ ] am I gonna
get embarrassed right so [ __ ] Opie
just kind of finagles his way and goes
you do state them right I go [ __ ] and
save them is like all right hey waiting
this [ __ ] oh that sucks he's like I told
you I'm the transporter he's like you do
me better than me [ __ ] wow
it's on YouTube shut up
okay you're walking around now the black
guy's here
why'd you gotta run off like uh
he's Egyptians that's [ __ ]
Statham's a cool dude that's a great
impressive
trick like you know he was a diver he
was a professional diver I didn't know
that when he had it you could look it up
he's like a diver like they show him
dive hide dice
yeah what he keeps getting sexier
yeah it was cool he was very cool man oh
man sexy guy cool guy yeah badass badass
you know just a bad [ __ ] you go
oh I see white yeah he's that dude he'd
be a decent bomb he would be fantastic
his bonds yeah I'll kind of want elbow
for Bond man I want elbow
look I usually hate black people taking
white Rolls Jesus Christ
Rocky no what about the mermaid
mermaid's white dude oh no mermaids are
from Syria [ __ ] out of here
yeah in the coast of Africa and Syria
yeah all right so they're Arabic they're
not even white in fact very
light-skinned Arabs okay okay they're
they're called yeah
hell
[Laughter]
yeah
shut up Joe you wouldn't have dark skin
if you were underwater yeah
the sun reflects it goes through the
water [ __ ] you that's embarrassing he's
like listen fine we don't have to put
too fine although honestly angler fish
are definitely black your skin would be
dark
my biggest creatures are translucent
no he brought up some good boys if Paul
Moody were alive uh-oh
let me tell you something Paul moody
right he was like okay dude it was
better Paul Mooney [ __ ] with uh
Anthony on you guys ever listening
goes on on open Anthony he [ __ ] with
Anthony so bad really like I remember
the first time I listened to it I didn't
understand how funny Paul Mooney was
he's so good so I was like this you know
I was a white guy from Mechanicsburg
like this guy's saying stuff I don't
like and then you get a little older and
you realize he's literally just [ __ ]
with cookies
God damn truth oh my God mermaid a
mermaid can be black they want it to be
a goddamn catfish
that's a great Paul Mojo was that was
that a mermaid that was a goddamn seal
you know God damn [ __ ]
dude Paul Mooney
I didn't see I see that with Paul Mooney
there's a lot of the the racial stuff
yeah of course at white people so I I
didn't understand it so I was not in on
the job but once you know once you
realize he's being a dick all right and
he knows he's being funny right but the
thing is with him with him and Anthony
like he knew what he was doing dude
these guys came from the 50s bro like
these guys were from the 50s and the 60s
when he was legitimately going I used to
drink out of colored water fountains
yeah I got a problem with white people
yeah he had people think it was like
yeah we were around him and Richard
Pryor came from Richard prys from Peoria
Illinois not that far from Chicago
[ __ ] he had yeah he had to [ __ ]
drink out of they had to go through the
back door and [ __ ] like that you ever
see that you ever see that roast of uh
oh it was fantastic prior talking with
about being gay he's like Paul's a [ __ ]
really hard I just want to get ahead of
it because
it's incredible what are you saying I'm
gonna say he goes I'm gonna say this
before you
and I bombed so hard I was a kid I was
21 I shouldn't have been there but I
[ __ ] killed something oh you were
Jewish so you were there
I I killed an audition to get in there
and they [ __ ] and then the actual
roast I bombed so [ __ ] hard was it
Omarosa yeah yeah
he's intro for me he goes this next
comic said he's a he's a fan of uh Bill
Hicks George Carlin Richard Pryor and uh
Sam Kinison I knew all of them all dead
all close friends of mine Samurai
everybody Jesus Christ that's my intro
wow did you wear the sailor hat
I did wow and I went down with the ship
hard
it was [ __ ] ugly but uh no Mooney was
cool he was a cool cool dude even though
I bombed my dick off he was still very
cool put you around some great that was
fantastic fantastic
I remember the first time I met this is
a great story I remember the first time
I met Godfrey you can't I went I was in
school I was at Kutztown University okay
I was on the Student Activities board
when he was there and I booked a comedy
show and it was you as the headliner
because we saw you at NACA oh God
remember that for campus activities
okay Jason went up bombed his ass off
did pop locks and I was talking to Jason
I don't get him man
yeah yeah
you went up you crushed and then I was
talking to you afterwards because you're
you're one of your credits in your intro
was it might have been your only credit
at the time probably was he's the
warm-up for The Cosby Show yeah oh you
didn't know that and eight hours I have
to do that sure
for the second Cosby do Bill Cosby
I know you got a good Bill Cosby amen
you know what you got to do
I know you got a nice Bill Cosby oh you
know what you gonna do for it I was
talking to you outside because
I was so enamored I was so enamored yeah
and I was like because I wanted to do
comedy I hadn't figured it out yet you
still haven't yeah
can you do Cosby talking to young
children no listen listen
I said to you what was it like what is
Bill Cosby like and you said you know
what's funny people think he doesn't
curse oh he does he cursed you started
doing Cosby cursing because bitching on
the set because so please do you would
do this like when they because he first
of all other than all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's been going on he's genius he was
genius that [ __ ] when it came to
this they knew what they were getting
into those groups
and then he would you know of course
when the camera's roll he wasn't cursing
it was it felt like it was it was the
first time I'd ever talked to anybody
that worked in actual Show Business and
when you were telling me that I was like
this is it I feel like I was my own
private tabloid when I lived in Queens I
lived in Queens yeah it was it was
caught from the story studio right next
door to Sesame Street I live right by
there didn't [ __ ] know I I remember
I'm warming up the crowd it's like two
300 people so you're talking you're
showing everybody the different parts of
the studio because I have to bring Dr
Cosby out Bring Cosby out Felicia
was a famous Indian comedic actor Dougie
dog I brought him out and and then I saw
the lady one of the lady from Sesame
Street like hanging out in the top and I
look I go oh [ __ ] this lady from Sesame
Street everyone's like oh my God it's
sleeve for sesame's I said why are you
over here she goes you know we're right
next door
holy [ __ ] I didn't know and then I see
Gordon the ball hit black dude in the
elevator what the [ __ ] see Elmo yes I
saw Kevin whatever and I went and they
took me on a tour almost teared the [ __ ]
up it was unbelievable wow they're
making the doing the puppets and I was
like what it [ __ ] you up I don't give
[ __ ] who you are you're gonna be like
holy [ __ ] yeah just Kermit the Frog this
is [ __ ] crazy yeah
you see some of them like the puppet
yeah yeah and then you see snuffle up
because you know on some rig
kids would be crying if they see him
like that would be a big deal we did a
nasty show at Montreal uh we Otto and uh
George came down and watching Otto take
the puppet apart and it was disturbing
it was a server because he was like he
was sitting there with the puppet across
job he's like that crowd [ __ ] sucked
man boo
oh and it goes into a compartment which
makes it more upsetting it's like here's
the head part
[Music]
yeah no because I remember because I was
there when Cosby's son was murdered I
was working at the time I was roommates
from Mike Epps and I go and Leslie you
mix with Mike Epps and Leslie Jones was
sleeping on our couch big [ __ ]
in the couch I was like who the [ __ ] is
this that's a huge twist
my next guest wow big
good stuff that's a big guest wow
you're gonna be a star
and I was like yo and then his son was
murdered I came to the studio I said oh
where's Doug Cosley oh he had an
emergency oh okay I didn't know this yet
then I go back home and I turn a TV and
it's his son his car murder this
[ __ ] came back a week later and
did stand up he did stand up about his
the funeral
killed murders you know the thing about
funerals
no no doubt really he talked about what
should we put in the the casket it was
[ __ ] dope and and had people crying
and laughing crying laughing and he just
tosses the mic to me and I gotta follow
that [ __ ] oh my God and then you follow
that and then you just like hey copy
everybody and just keep you guys ever
murder a guy's son
speaking of murders you murdered murder
murdered who and that was the Menendez
brothers they're in the news I remember
when Cosby challenged me one time
because I was because I would be on a
roll sometimes I'd be killing killing
then one day they said Dr Causey wants
to come out and do a set oh really
because he never comes out they go he
wants to come so I was like yeah so he
came out
destroyed the place
tossed the mic to me and said follow
that wow I walked away I said I love I
love [ __ ] I brought his punk ass out
he was that he I was only four years in
the comedy wow that was fine I was like
what am I gonna do he just I have to
work I have to keep going I just keep
talking to the audience but he told me
to follow that [ __ ] because he was
hearing me he would hear me I'll be I
would be killing dude like because oh
he'd be in the green room just like this
guy he's like
yeah
I bet you can't stay awake
I'm about to knock this kid and you can
walk into his office and talk to him he
was cool as [ __ ] like that I remember
walking to his office I said hey uh and
he had his cigar man it was all Cosby I
remember explaining this to Pete
corielli when it happened the day it
happened I saw Pete after that and I was
he was just had a cigar you know he was
like Hey
you know and I said yeah I just you know
some advice you know I don't know what
the [ __ ] is your advice I've been doing
for you he said and I remember he goes
you've been doing four years at that
point he goes riding you got the right
son you got to write you got to put it
on the paper I remember this [ __ ] you
got to write man he goes you know Sinbad
he knocks it out the park send him back
he loves him
black Dan Cook
[Applause]
no no I'm saying as far as disrespect
goes that a guy that does kill I love oh
yeah I love it there's a guy
his presence was incredible
I would love to have Jane cookies
the aliens when he goes there was a wet
and [ __ ] and he dumps the whole [ __ ]
box Kennedy starts doing the [ __ ]
alien I was like I loved it this [ __ ]
guy is so [ __ ] and then he had a tank
top one he said [ __ ] a suit [ __ ] hit
a tank top then he jumps into camera
what's the movie with Arnold and
cinnamon
Turbo Man you know what I'm talking
about oh yeah yeah
all the way classic great movie Arnold
and Sinbad the Dane joke in the in the
half hour when he goes when you were
talking he talks about waiting online
DMV yeah he goes you're all just waiting
there and he's doing like
all the [ __ ] you do anyway he goes but
we're all thinking the same thing God
are you telling somebody else's funny
story yes that joke is so funny please
[Music]
first time I saw DeRosa
OTB first yeah first time DeRosa yeah
Jenny Craig now the uh the first time I
saw drawers that's all I could get one
yeah
Gotham Comedy Club it was a benefit and
it was a terrible show I was in the
audience this is like the first comedy
show I've seen it was a terrible show
Joe he was killing I thought I found a
very funny
it is it is
but you didn't deserve to bomb you
weren't doing well and you were talking
about your ex-girlfriend you said I
already feel bad about the uh the
breakup now I gotta feel bad about the
breakup jokes and I was like that's just
such a funny line
is a damn genius we loved her
instructing a joke bro and he saw that
it had scaffolding over here to do
comedy again we'd love to have you know
what you do I'm still doing it
when you said yo just cop doubt there's
a [ __ ] video of Richard Pryor
[ __ ] on Milton Berle oh he's going
like this man shut your ass up God damn
this [ __ ] hell [ __ ] right oh my
God
pick your spots baby pick your spots
he's [ __ ] getting pissed your spots
man Pryor was [ __ ] Next Level dude
when Pryor was did you see the prior
when he's in drugs outside yes
think about Charlie Chapman that
[ __ ] didn't say [ __ ]
[ __ ] him [ __ ] that's the one
what's it like we're gonna cheat well
there and he's like you're just like oh
dude I'm not gonna say it but yeah
what's it like with Gene Wilder what's
he saying
well there's a is an F
that [ __ ]
what what is something give us some
Impressions you can do that would like
that we haven't heard because I know you
can do everybody who I can't do
everybody you do a lot no he doesn't
mean Paul Mercurio but no one knows who
that is hey yo what about the black guy
Paul was an 80s
yeah you [ __ ] with my girlfriend again
you'll be wearing your nose in the back
of your head let's get out of here
Dragon smoothie hold on that's my entire
ly
hold on a second
give us another that we haven't heard
you could do so many good Impressions
you got a good Trump you're Trump's good
oh [ __ ] Trump thing
Warriors
very good very good oh yeah
it's very good there's a lot of guys
doing uh a lot of people doing me you're
a very good impersonator
yeah it's not bad nothing now James
yoderosa what a pig
disgusting Big I would love to put the
country on your shoulders but Joe it
might slide off
I'm a very good comedian I could be a
comedian wow a lot of guys a lot of guys
say Joe's built like a worm I don't say
that but Joe is built like a worm
he looks like the Men in Black aliens
grew up
Mike Turner Mike Turner very good very
good that was incredible oh we did it
that's really impressive so that's the
only impression we can still do
something that's funny it would be nice
to do a white and black trump it would
be fine it'd be nice to just can we do
two dudes that watch Trump enough that
they adopted it and then our lives like
just us going to a store dude yeah I'd
like uh mint skull do you have minced
skull
I would like detergent Tigers the best I
need the pods I don't really do pain on
the street dog [ __ ] that's Joe Nick a
black and all the guy's name uh he's on
uh [ __ ] he's on Twitter uh but yeah
jail Colvin does a nice Trump
he's a funny guy he owed us some great
impressions Bob the Bono's is nasty his
is good too Bob the Bono you know I'm
not sure who that one is this video
we're here so Jamie Foxx doing the
Donald Trump impression and he's
responsible he goes he goes he was in a
show called in living colored I know you
can't say that anymore
the white guy was the funniest I know we
can't say
I know Jamie I opened up for Jamie in
Indianapolis what do you mean not at all
I mean I just don't hang with him like
that I I know him but I know I'm not his
best friend yeah
yeah I mean he's good for you I'm quick
to be like yeah me and him are best
friends I've talked to him twice
no not just the last time anybody
anybody I talked to twice I'm like Jamie
was on that the set of uh law-abiding
citizen because I'm good friends with
Gerard Butler so she did call me in
Philly they shot it yeah Gerard's like
yo come down man hang out boom so I came
down and I saw Jamie on the set and that
was about it
the art is cool [ __ ] right unbelievable
how did you not get in Any Given Sunday
I mean I wasn't the baseball really
doing [ __ ] did you do do you do a dead
show
oh yeah all right I saw the twinkle in
there was my favorite impression of all
time there's a guy named C King it was
that the guy who was doing it on reds
yeah he's unfucking believable his his
Denzel is it's it's like you close your
eyes you go [ __ ] but that's his
best one everything else he tries to do
Steve Harvey but he's trying to copy
mine which I get what you have Steve
Harvey Steve always goes I'ma whoop your
ass boy
dude you know it was a rough one for me
I do Nate Diaz he got me who's Nathan oh
he's a UFC fighter me and him went out
you guys are buddies though right yeah
but we've talked twice
[Laughter]
as friends uh dinner and he was like I
don't sound like that oh damn for real I
was genuinely I was like yeah you're
right I mean well people are like dude
that's fine
I was on a podcast with Shannon Sharp
I've been in the NFL for a long time
forgiving my grandmother with it if you
a frog you better jump skill you know
but I do it man he was on the podcast
with me and the dude was like Yo God for
you to a [ __ ] Shin shot okay God damn
it and then you know I used to get mad
at the time when people used to imitate
me but now I see once you uh at a
certain level that people people that
means you're famous now that means
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] warms up with
250. so yeah have you seen that [ __ ] but
you had to do him in front of him I did
him on on a podcast like on a audio
thing anyway he was cool as [ __ ] dude
[Laughter]
we started Denzel with
first doing Denzel because I had no I
never thought about doing Denzel then I
saw Dean do I go oh wow he found nuances
of dental going yeah all right all right
you know that whole [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's what I was like [ __ ] so I came on
my own so but it was more like a subtle
dense I was like all right so what are
we gonna do huh is that what you doing
everybody in here huh so that's where I
got my from Dean Dean was the one that
set it off who's the guy on Comic View
that did it as his set
come with you on there was a dude as his
set black guy right there was a no it
was Big Jay oakerson
here's a dude who did poppy on poppy on
BT poppy he's like Poppy's never gonna
tell on you yeah poppy will be like no
no that's none of my business now
obviously that's not how it went what
the [ __ ] I thought you guys would know I
thought you guys were students of the
game I didn't know you were making
sandwiches and gave up oh yo how's your
car
dude
I apologize
I thought he shut down after you said
you made sandwiches and gave up
[ __ ] no I was just being mean
because my story sucked so I tried to
yeah my favorite Denzel is The Equalizer
two when he's at the kitchen table with
uh the guy that plays
mandalorians and he goes tell me not
true tell me it's not what he knows he
caught the guy that he killed that that
was a good man equalizer is amazing so
give up no please please
get out of here hey knock it off dude is
there any questions I don't like that
you're building scenarios
I literally made sure Godfrey was the
last guest because I knew he would
energize us and what the [ __ ] you guys
are ready to go oh no dude we [ __ ] up
I was trying to book guests and I was
like God if he's gonna come with [ __ ]
because I'm on drunk I get it you're
undrunk and you're at the front you're
last the seller all the time I knew you
yeah it would be [ __ ] pure because I
got [ __ ] to do during the day what are
you doing during the day I do odd
there's auditions all the time you
always got me tab dancing for that you
know I got to be like I told you [ __ ]
because I remember everybody was doing
Christopher Walken yeah that was big
like Jay Moore was doing it a lot of
people were doing I said can I do
Christy for walking
I don't know then I was and I watched
everybody has this you know a man yeah
everyone was doing that yeah then I was
listening to Chris walking okay he's
from New York city so I was just very
like subtle like you know comedy very
difficult
you know
I've always wanted to do stand-up but
I'm scared you know
yeah so
how about you can you do Jack who
Nicholson no I don't do Jack who else
can you name Jack was like such a
mainsay of every half everybody yeah I
never would always be like hey hey
yeah I'm Jack Nicholson they would
always turn around and go you know what
it might be him by the way the whole
crowd would be like holy [ __ ] that's him
a Nicholson hack impression I was like
yeah it's wonderful it's fun we had a
great joke over there where he goes I am
one of the ten men in America that does
not do a Jackman actually that sounded
like Jack Nicholson I remember uh
Byron Allen with you know Comics
Unleashed you ever go if you watch you
ever he's in a big lawsuit right here he
won he won he won against something
Donald McDowell he won hell yeah by the
way this is basically Byron Allen we're
like all right so you know don't wait
wait wait no this is what I want to tell
you yeah so my first
Comics Unleashed 2006 was with Dennis
Miller and they were like he goes Byron
goes yo Godfrey I got Dennis Miller I'm
like okay cool I love Dennis Miller his
off-white album is my favorite album so
I was like uh cool he goes and people
like yeah be careful he's like a right
wing like I don't give a [ __ ] he's a
comic man who gives a [ __ ] he was the
nicest man he loves Comics comedians so
we're stead we're all we're sitting next
to each other we're lab everybody's
having fun and he goes he goes hey Byron
you want to make this a little more
corny huh oh I heard you like dogs go oh
he was [ __ ] with them because they
know each other but it was it was
[ __ ] hilarious then he's like we're
talking then he gives me his number he
said anytime you need some you know
advice so I leave a message for him say
hey Mr Miller thanks for being cool so I
used to have you know I used to put like
sounds on a voicemail you know how you
put [ __ ] you know I'm not here right now
leave a message you know [ __ ] like that
oh yeah definitely I did that he left he
left a message it was around Christmas
he goes hey Cha-Cha I guess that was
Bruce Lee nice Merry Christmas Dennis
Miller bam wow I kept it for years I met
him once I did a show he took over Larry
King's old like weird interview show and
it was me and I was kind of so
Starstruck that I was so I was just off
I sucked really because he was just so
nice and I was kind of like yeah okay
babe
that was weird that was weird
that was weird that hurt you got a deep
tissue on that hurt dude it hurt give me
some dead silly [ __ ]
you're doing wing nut left wing uh
[ __ ] Dennis Miller Impressions
you won't give me a little [ __ ] easy
I just gave it to you I understand this
worked up
Christopher Walken once I did it
that's I gave you a piece of this
son of a [ __ ] you know my damn nurse
I'm tired of you Joe
I'm tired I'm tired of your passion bro
your dumb passions
would be like ew I hate you yes you're
the worst [ __ ] your legs
I woke up to a voicemail from G Robinson
once 10 years ago I just I see it on my
phone Hey listen he goes uh I'll just
sit here thinking about your dumb face
I'm gonna drive up to Harlem and knock
your [ __ ] teeth out
we always do that we'll we'll send
messages to each other we'll send
messages to each other we just go Hey
Joe yuck
oh it's a road trip I was driving I
drive my car back from I bought a Bronco
in L.A and I'll drive it across country
beautiful car by the way old school a
new Bronco the new one but it looks old
school but I bought it and I was driving
it back from Atlanta to New York and I
was driving through a dip all through it
I was driving through Nashville and you
called me when I was in Nashville
and you go hey stupid where are you I'll
tell you where I am I'm walking out of a
nice racist Cracker Barrel I feel good
in my heart right now
I should tell them what you really are
Keith wrong he's one of those Egyptians
so hard you and Dante called me I was
working yeah I was literally walking out
of a Cracker Barrel
[Music]
to the most most militant Brothers like
where you at bro
walking right out of a Cracker Barrel
if you're on the road they're not bad oh
no I would go there my mother would take
me to all that [ __ ] chicken fried steak
is solid [ __ ] I heard the breakfast is
fantastic that's very good I've been had
it in so long it's been so long too I
went in for breakfast and I got the I
got potatoes with the sausage gravy and
I got Fried Chicken as well hey that's
not hey you got Fried Chicken it was
very good
will you save it and I Vita is such a
food snot forgot you were here
shut up
dude we're in uh Buffalo and and Vito we
got a [ __ ] take out oysters oh
we ordered the food and then they didn't
have the app that we wanted and then the
waitress took it upon herself the for
the uh at the club it was like oh they
should like hey guys so I look at it I'm
like oh we can't eat this [ __ ] that's
not even on ice and Peter goes shut up
we're fine so Vito eats him and I'm that
idiot where I'm like yeah I'll [ __ ] it
I'll eat it so I did too Vito gets off
stage he goes I can't I was [ __ ] up
my attire it's brutal I'm [ __ ] I was
burping and everything
oysters bro oh dude we had yeah
we were celebrating it out of the show I
figured
and it's a go box I figured they
wouldn't allow it if it was gonna be bad
if you didn't need it I never would it
should be on that ice man and you sit
down and eat that [ __ ] bro and we
realized that the fact that we only had
vicious diarrhea put it in a plastic bag
we got so lucky we yeah
they were terrible it did not feel good
but on the road no oyster that's wild no
never again we got lucky that we only
had diarrhea out of that [ __ ] did that
diarrhea hit you on stage next day no
yeah it was next day diarrhea never hits
on stage stage whatever reason your [ __ ]
about [ __ ] shuts down yeah
it's like your body knows but five
seconds before you're called you might
shoot your bed you have to [ __ ] well I
should everyone takes like a dump before
it it's the worst dog it's amazing you
don't even have to eat anything you just
go bomb yeah then you're ready to
[ __ ] go take 10 tiny dick pisses yeah
no but I mean like on stage you did it
in front of people you just said oh no
but I'm farting up there while talking
about you that's crazy you're like a
girl
what's it called the cinnamon one a
Fireball Fireball I've done nothing
shut up I've never seen you I knew you'd
say
I saw you warming up God for you there's
some type of funny impression while you
do the shot yeah as we close to Norman
will you do something what did you do
Christianity
no I didn't say that I got a lot of gay
guys here
hold up my shot's too small my shot's
too small yeah of course yeah that's
where you're all good okay
we've got a lot of straight guys too
pretty straight of them pretty straight
pretty jumping what do you got Cosby for
Norman
I could do Norm Macdonald
Norm you'd either catch shaved Norm
drunk or bearded Norm sober or bearded
Norm drug I would catch him and dim he
goes yeah God man man I saw you up there
man you're talented man yeah you know
he's like you're really really funny
they ever do SNL yeah so now I go no he
goes [ __ ] them because they hate me and
NBC hates me man yeah he called me and
hit me with that he was like really yeah
I thought you know he was like comedy I
thought not a lot of guys in comedy
anymore
you know what he means yeah yeah yeah
you know what he means
Sean uh uh
which opening for him and I was in
Atlanta and I was gonna interview him
you got that right the hit new whiskey
it's Bodega cat it's their whiskey it's
called It's Your Whiskey yeah we're
selling it you have a whiskey look at
that he didn't even know it was theirs
he said that wasn't so bad yeah
meanwhile
he wins there's always a cat in a bodega
it's a good whiskey I don't care
it's not Buffalo Trace he's like all
right well it's Mark so shut up hey it'd
be nice
I love Joe Rooney's the greatest one
but yo he's wrong on this one
and I'm like what's your story no no I'm
not saying that to like tell the story
I'm saying like ah [ __ ] all right nobody
wants to hear this Joe on camera yeah we
want to hear your story
hey I'm gonna hear your story yeah you
know what I like about it yeah yeah
you're very excited the uh yeah best
stories every day every time I see Joe
Ross I'm like oh we love it yeah
you're one of my favorite dudes
everybody thinks you're the best
everybody loves you Jojo everybody loves
you wow this is pure drunk laundry
everybody loves you pure drunk love I'd
say Marquette probably has the most
friends out of anybody here Mark has a
lot of friends yeah which is weird
because he doesn't like anyone exactly
yeah he does buddy but he has a lot of
friends
I watch a lot of their videos
what's yours do you have a lot of Clips
I don't you watch my videos
watch you go live sometimes I'm like I
hope he doesn't see this video
I love your videos I think you're funny
all I do is just try to go with the
flood get on lives I just tried to do it
you know if you're not on a hit show you
gotta have good social media within
weeks you gotta do this [ __ ] yeah right
you know I'm one of those guys and
everybody's on [ __ ] podcast going
what the [ __ ] how is Godfrey not uh what
the [ __ ] going on yeah so I got to use
usually doing more podcasts and look at
Jesus Christ you can't hear everybody
was like go go go you go everyone knows
that's what I was like before you got
here
we go okay
but you know it's [ __ ] up it's people
when you have you know people in
positions they don't bring you in they
don't they just don't do it and I know a
lot of people in [ __ ] and they just kind
of nah you know what I mean it's like
it's like I can do a lot of voices and
my buddy from high school my [ __ ]
high school teammate created Dexter's
Laboratory
yeah that's my from 16 I know I'm saying
we were teammates high school he did
he's Transylvania he's Powerpuff Girls
he's Samurai Jack he's doing Popeye he's
doing Papa I don't know if it's
happening but yeah that's my high school
buddy like I've never done a voiceover
for him though
I don't ask but I just never that is
never asked me to come down and make a
[ __ ] sandwich yeah you're like you
want to talk [ __ ] dude no I'm sorry I'm
sorry
I'd love it
hey shut up over there dude
yeah Samurai Jack and Clone Wars he did
all that she does so much he's an
animator he's like man I remember oh
dude let's get on Clone Wars
get this guy to get us our clothes
[Laughter]
fatty dude oh [ __ ] for real why you call
me fat you're [ __ ] jacket beautiful
jugs Jiggles you've been here like six
hours
yeah he was here me and Mitch Hedberg
did new faces wow me and him were the
last two guys at this horrible showcase
at the comedy nest in Montreal and it's
just me and everybody's bomb is [ __ ]
horrible and I'm Gonna Last I'm just
coming from Chicago and hedberg's long
hair he's like hey what's how you doing
man what's your name I said uh God for
you they got Mitch Mitch miss hitberg I
said oh cool it's like I'm going after
you I think you're gonna I'm going after
you I said oh cool so I everybody's
bombing I go up I'm used to killing and
[ __ ] with my goofy [ __ ] I did okay I did
decent didn't do what I wanted to do I
was like uh that [ __ ] murder
because no one had ever seen that style
before right he was just down there like
this I thought he was different he never
looked up he just was like yeah so uh I
just want to say it was just like what
the [ __ ] that's how I knew Mitch for I
knew Mitch since 98. wow and that's why
he always showed me love he's like
coffee man what's up man hey man and
then when I saw him when he was limping
when he was doing the heroin [ __ ] I saw
him as CBS in La like so not too long
before he passed away I saw him limping
yes where's he from
Minneapolis yeah oh for some reason so
when I started I knew this dude in
Florida that was like he claimed he was
a manager of his and he was like when I
talked to him I was like man you got to
stop doing these drugs he was like you
think the Beatles came up with Sergeant
Pepper sober and I was like all right
he'd come back
keep going
that was me quoting somebody else Yeah
man so that's all your stories I feel
like Michael Jordan might have pulled it
out I'm lucky I don't know titty [ __ ]
you dude
yeah
when I started in Chicago
it was me Bernie Mac Bernie Mac had it I
used to do comedy for MJ yeah wait for
Michael Jordan it was when I was just
like my first two years in comedy was me
Deon Cole d-ray Davis Corey Holcomb it
was all the Chicago guys and you know
Common would be there we I knew Kanye
for a long time and um a lot of it's
awesome
day and then they brought his video to
my house in Harlem before they released
it because have you seen the documentary
did it he's from Chicago oh yeah he's a
filmmaker I'm sorry isn't DeRay the one
in the video like without an arm I spit
right with the Y and the Y to the wire
yeah they brought that to my place
before they released it they said yo you
got to check out this video we're about
to release I said well bring I was on
them Lennox they brought it I said oh
that's gonna be dope it's so Chicago
blah blah blah and then um we should do
open mics that Bernie Mac had a variety
show at the Cotton Club and so we would
go down five times we would go there and
yeah Bernie tough up yeah and then
Michael would come because the Bulls
were winning at the time so it'll be
Michael Scottie Pippen was a a dick the
whole time see before Larson Pippen was
dating Michael's son well yeah this this
Scotty's ex-wife is banging Michael
Jordan's son that's crazy it does suck
for you Jordan Jordan was Jordan was
Jordan was always cool right now right
now Jordan was cool I met him a few
times and they're not on good terms so
it does suck for Scotty
yeah that was that was right in the
middle nasty
when they won their second Championship
they were going who you with because
Bernie would say hey [ __ ] who
you with
and so Jordan would go who you with it
was like it was maybe the best NBA
players
Larry Bird
no pistol Pistol Pete Maravich Pistol
Pete Louisiana oh was he from Louisiana
oh yeah yeah Louisiana baby oh wow look
at that dude I think Bob Koozie
wipe it underhand white people invented
the no look pass
[Laughter]
no dude I will say dunk best slam dunk
I'll be honest that was you guys of
course the no look passes when they were
like I don't want to look at the black
guy let me just give it
it was actually a racial thing and I
didn't want to look at the black guys
actually just threw it without looking
for people
that's almost like
reviews
I did it already yeah
Robinson
Robinson your children Robinson you're
like dude
on Earth
I [ __ ] love it dude
yo you're Joe De Robinson goodbye I'm so
glad you didn't bail I was so pumped
Shane was coming I was always going to
bail Joe
Robinson you're the best black player
you're the best black player of all time
Tim Duncan dude fundamentals
we had such a [ __ ] budget that veto was
on that episode [ __ ] the budget was we
we uh our budget was so bad that we
couldn't get a second guess so we
literally switched people out while
Lambie was on the panel and lambeer
turned me after the episode goes did you
trick me into doing two episodes and I
said I'm sorry and he goes respect he
like he respected that I [ __ ] copied
seven feet by the way and he can shoot
it I gotta I gotta get a billion beer
Notre Dame he went to Notre Dame did he
go to Dame
white guy
he was a mountain obviously he was good
at basketball he played great you shoot
at three he literally he was like they
were like these are the bad boys of the
NBA literally all he did was foul the
[ __ ] up I love the documentary yeah that
Doc is fine that was awesome
they made Jordan better the Bad Boys
Pistons with my horn and Isaiah Dumas
and Isaiah no no wait a minute it's John
Sally who was a good friend of mine
biggest penis uh Lisa Ann said John
Sally the porn star yeah she said he had
the biggest dick she's ever seen that
matches his height yeah funny John Sally
he's a yoga Dennis Rodman Rodman was the
chef
Vinnie Johnson you microwave with the
threes nasty all right let's go back to
Bill and beer and how great he was
basketball is a [ __ ] dude I think Robin
is trying to get Jesus yeah we love it
you guys switched he's trying because
for some reason he went to North Korea
love to be uh baseball we used to love
it today's our day Sandy Koufax
selling
Ryan
facing Ryan did you see the documentary
phenomenal [ __ ] badass the Nolan Ryan
DACA what a good guy is I love him what
a good guy
a regular dude with a [ __ ] heater and
then Bo Jackson charged the mound and he
said I'll never Jackson sorry no it was
off Robert Ventura Robin Ventura yeah
[Music]
Bo Jackson charged that man Nolan Ryan
is dead he's dead sorry to say somebody
goes that was a mistake I'll never be
the non-aggressor Bo Jackson hit a home
run
the [ __ ] out of him he probably gunned
it at his head yeah Bo Jackson broke
bats on his leg and his head
biggest freak uh remember when he ran up
there you are Gary
yes he ran up the wall he ran up the
[ __ ] wall dude I didn't realize that
could be uh we received his bed what'd
you say Bo Jackson was the biggest freak
in sports oh don't be racist I know yeah
he's one of my favorites Deion Sanders
was kind of a freak too yeah yeah
playing baseball and football yeah have
you seen Dion lately with Jackson State
no yeah it's pretty fun he's like I'm
gonna tell you all right now
I'm gonna tell y'all right now we gotta
win you gotta have that attitude
don't disappoint your mama or your dad
or me he's he's like very like prime
time I'm Deion Sanders you guys are
lucky to be people thought I was Deion
sander they thought I look like him
said people used to come and say yo Dion
Sanders I'm like come on man no that's
pretty good [ __ ] am I doing here with
you it's actually pretty nice you get
Dion I love that Dion's his son his
son's the court his son's the
quarterback of the team too yeah for
Jackson State right does he have the
speed of his father I don't know but
he's playing his son's a quarterback
freshman quarterback and he starts but
Dion got his toes like two toes
amputated
a diabetic why I don't know you always
nice watching that you documentary where
they were like everybody that went to
Florida state was a [ __ ] preppy [ __ ]
all the you guys were like [ __ ] Deion
Sanders that [ __ ] sellout oh and Dion
was just like gold chains like [ __ ]
those [ __ ]
Dion's the [ __ ] Dion was fantastic ran a
4-1 get the [ __ ] out of here he's fast
as [ __ ] I remember people didn't believe
it they didn't believe he ran a 4-140.
then he goes I'm gonna do this [ __ ] one
more time
I'm doing a podcast with Julian Edelman
right now and this is
the coolest guy you'll ever meet and on
top is hilarious amount of respect he
gets versus the like what the what the
guests look at me as like literally Kurt
Warner looked at me like I you decide
I can't I couldn't I knew he would not
like me so I doubled down and kept
making jack off jokes and every every
cut to him is just like
why do you like you
I think Kurt Warner worked in a grocery
store yeah he did yeah but he's also
religious and he's a good person yeah
they made like a Christian movie
recently oh yeah yeah yeah but Julian's
the [ __ ] man he's cool he's the
greatest show on Turf yeah he's a Jew
but Julian's a [ __ ] man he's a great
turns out Torrey Holt was blessed with
white God
Isaac Bruce Isaac Bruce Isaac the Bruce
Ricky Pro isn't it wide receiver yeah
Marshall Park was blessed Marshall Faulk
was the nastiest running back I ever
watched really I mean just live that
dude was on another level he just burned
dudes I like Peter Sanders Barry Sanders
too for sure all right who do you think
the top five whites go ahead
what football Hitler oh anything well I
don't know Sports oh what happened what
happened top five whites Larry whites
yeah everything he's up there
[Music]
they weren't considered white at first
boxes so why am I going to bring them
off here
[Laughter]
Rocky Marciano Tyson Fury I put Joe
White I'm talking about white white
jacket for the Jack Dempsey
what no Flair I'm talking white Jack no
place
Johnson
greatest boxers ever yeah but he was
Italian no I don't know if it was super
white though Italians are Mediterranean
oh that's a good one I'm talking
about numbers compared to a black guy
yeah if we were talking racism and I
said no no uh
Italians were categorized as white after
a while when they got to that was they
look like they were from India go watch
the Ken Burns PBS Italian American and
you'll see what the [ __ ] they look like
shout out to Kevin Burns yeah
Fernandez Tony Hernandez the new Ken
Burns Holocaust doc shut up
it's actually a good call who should be
in the Hall of Fame now then we're
talking like Ric Flair no no no Hubble
Hubble how about Randy seven yeah
one cool dude yeah brother yeah you
don't understand
wrestling why it's greatest of all time
took it to the yeah it's the next
levels of wrestling I met Hulk Hogan
greatest question
and I entered he said you want to you
want to meet a Hulk Hogan I said yeah
he's like you know I'm wrestling now I
was like and we meet Hulk Hogan and we
do a little sketch he's like what's up
brother how you doing Governor
B Shack and [ __ ] Hulk Hogan you got
Jack Godfrey
oh Shaq DM facetimes me every other week
yeah so he tries to dude
before you do another ancillary
[Music]
good for Sam's thanks Sam you're taking
requests
out dude shut up shut the [ __ ] up no
movie with him that's how he's doing
Chicago shut the [ __ ] up
when you do it like that even if
someone's talking to me Shut the [ __ ] up
man we gotta wrap this up this has been
I don't know oh my God we got a dinner
reservations well I think I think one
more shot for you guys you guys you
gotta come to dinner then right now
we've been here for four hours drinking
you've been here we've been here longer
than that yeah
Jesus Christ
foreign
[Applause]
before we wrap up can I make one quick
toast God free everybody can we make one
quick toast okay uh I'm gonna get you
right it's gonna be good all right Matt
Peter first off Matt Peters thank you
for helping put this all together great
second off to Mark Norman who we love
and who uh who's getting married
great choice thanks for having me guys
hey great choice you're all here
honestly you're all here because we love
all you so thank you yeah
great comedians we're so happy that this
could uh
we'll see you all in hell
this is funny you guys
[Laughter]
yeah you're welcome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we might
be true